well let's get the latest analysis now
on the situation on the ground in
ukraine i'm now joined by retired vice
marshal sean bell who's also advisor at
universal defense and security solutions
and sean let's just focus in on the
southeast of the country just bring us
up to date with the developments there
well in mario despite uh president
putin's very uh public
direction to his generals uh to put a
ring of steel around the steel works so
not a fly can enter it in reality what's
actually happening is that the offensive
continues against those uh ukrainians
still trapped in the city um i think
well that's pretty heavy even though
some of the troops have been taken away
russian troops for the donbass it's
pretty evident that mario paul remains a
thorn in the side of putin and whilst
the fighting still goes on he can't
claim victory there further north i
think the fighting is pretty intense but
it tellingly it's over about a 300 mile
front uh in russian forces spread
themselves very thinly there's lots of
sporadic attacks probing the ukrainian
defenses and what seems likely to be
happening is a tension between the
russian military wanting to focus their
efforts to actually achieve a success
and the political direction which wants
rapid results to be able to announce the
people and it looks like the politics is
winning at the moment meanwhile whilst
they're doing a fairly limited front um
it the fighting will remain intensive
the ukrainians are certainly though uh
creating a lot of havoc and um treating
a lot of the russian forces and sean
ukraine says is hoping to get more
military um support from the u.s what
kind of weapons are we looking at and
crucially what impacts would it have
yes i think we've got as the whole uh
campaign has changed from being a whole
of the country to much more focused in
the donbass we've heard president
zielenski's language change from just
weapons weapons weapons to now heavy
weapons and the most recent military aid
from america one of the items is the
1.155 millimeter how it's a gun shown
here um they the americans originally
committed 18 of these guns they've now
committed another 78 of them together
with the vehicles that will tow them
around and also tellingly 144 000 rounds
of ammunition as well and of course
that'll be a mixture of high explosive
and illumination rounds and also
conducting some training outside of
ukraine to prepare the people this gun's
interesting because it first saw service
in 1942 it was a u.s army um gun it was
showed service in the second world war
uh in vietnam in and in korea so part of
you sort of wondering why is that an old
bit of weapon like this going out to
ukraine well reality is this augmented
with technology makes it much more
effective and nowadays the gun is only
as effective as what you can hit
these now link to radars which track the
rounds being fired to see where they
land and then can automatically put a
course correction in azimuth and
elevation on the gun so it hits its
target much more accurately and i think
that's particularly in the theater of
ukraine could be a really valuable asset
for them so then the obvious question
here is that these weapons are quite old
so
will they be guessing any new weapons at
all ukraine i think the yeah the mix of
weapons the americans announced the
other thing they announced were very new
was the 121 phoenix ghost unmanned air
vehicles that's not this at the moment
which is a very six year we've not seen
this thing deployed before it turns out
the americans will be chatting to the
ukrainians about their specific
requirements for the donbass and it
turns out that weapons that the
americans had already been developing
and had on the shelf could meet that
absolute requirement so we don't know
much about it we don't think it's been
deployed before the americans have used
the switchblade before which is here
which is in effect a a suicide drone it
flies finds its target attacks it and
then blows up and we believe that the
phoenix ghost has a similar sort of
capability but also with some optics
available so it can do some
reconnaissance identify targets
potentially send that information back
but it's a really interesting blend the
americans done it old and new but it's
specifically tailored to what ukraine
needs today
the challenge i think more widely is
that it's one thing getting these
weapons uh providing them to the
ukrainians is quite another how do you
get them from the point of entry
probably around on the on the west coast
border there all the way across to where
the fighting is happening in the past
when we've had handheld missiles or guns
you can put them in the boot of a car
they're relatively easy to hide 155
artillery and are not going to be easy
to hide in bulk and we're not the only
nations that have satellite technology
looking down so the security issues here
are significant and it will take time to
move them across and of course at the
moment in this conflict time is at a
premium absolutely so some further
support but of course that presents
further challenges as well that's right
sean bell thank you very much indeed